[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
super pumped to be talking about Shadows
desires and creativity
we have Midori joining us on the show
hello hi thanks so much for coming
thank you for having me I'm very very
excited for this for those that don't
know Midori's background Midori is an
elegant provocateur who educates on
subjects of sexuality BDSM and
self-expression helping people reframe
their place in the world and you can
find the links in the bio Ron Sheng calm
women's dominance weekend intensive at
Ford fm calm and all her other events at
FHP - Inc calm and check out her social
profiles twitter facebook Instagram
YouTube and patreon let's do this in the
Dory what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world oh man well it
depends if you are a Star Wars person or
Star Trek or something right
or Battlestar Galactica or yeah or a
David Lynch person right it's going to
depend I think
the future is in the hands of
stubborn dreamers
the stubborn dreamers right yeah I think
the future is in the hand of stubborn
dreamers you gotta be stubborn and but
you've got to have something that you're
dreaming towards I'm making the the the
stubbornness worth it and I think future
is in the hands of futures in the heart
of the empathetic love that
because we're in a place where
essentially the the battles not between
good versus evil but it's between the
empathetic and those who have lacking in
deep empathy like that frame a lot one
of the grand challenges of existing on
this rock together is figuring out how
to live on it harmoniously with nature
with what sustains us with each other
and that's to dream to be the stubborn
dreamers to dream that future and to get
there together and to realize we can
still compete and make ideas but live
cohesively with nature yeah
and to recognize that as species we've
come as species we are destroyed and
consumed right that's that's how the
organism survives I mean just a basic
digestive level you create right so we
need to take in things in order to we we
destroy and we consume the byproduct of
that hey the byproduct of that
biologically is [ __ ] alright but what do
you do with this [ __ ] right
do you take that [ __ ] and create manure
out of it or do you take [ __ ] and fling
it at each other hmm
and here heretofore there so thank you I
mean you know we destroy we consume we
do produce [ __ ] so what do we do with
this [ __ ]
and once long ago you know we took [ __ ]
and made fuel out of it
we took [ __ ] and grew food out of it
and dadaist artists have put [ __ ] in a
can and called it art as an art is [ __ ]
so now that we started the show
scatological e
and we talked about you know living in
harmony with nature but I think part of
it is that we may ignore that the cycle
of the natural cycle on this piece of
rock is a constant process of of matter
coming together and matter dissolving
matter coming together matter dissolving
and where are we in that cycle of matter
coming apart and matter coming back
together
I hope we're not gonna keep fleeing [ __ ]
at each other we're gonna use it yeah
good purposes a fertilizer
yeah a fertilizer and also see us in a
trajectory that's a more positive coming
together yeah and it does
yeah I've been flow like that and it's
the exponential technology age and the
crazy geopolitical stuff that's
happening to come together is critical
I'm not yeah yeah it can be a lot of
chaos and civilization collapse if we
don't so yeah empathy yeah and empathy
to to develop a world where empathic to
engage in empathy and compassion is a
social norm yeah I think that's true for
interpersonal relationship as well as
business design as well as urban design
taking a moment to be able to see the
same situation the Rashomon situation
from somebody else's perspectives right
you don't have to agree with them this
year to be able to take a moment say all
right you might see it in this frame
yeah would you call it a Rasha Rasha
among Russian one Russia among is the
Japanese movie that could a famous movie
in Japan where there was a crime that
happened at a temple gate and it is told
from the perspective of three different
people cool yeah yeah yeah that's how
you get it I love that it's so yeah
they'll get they'll get people to better
understand there as people say there's
always two sides to a story or three or
there's always eight billion
perspectives on the planet well now
there
so like take the Women's World Cup right
okay so let's take three different
perspectives did you from one one
person's perspective say the goalie
England goalie
we lost she may say from the team
captain of the Women's Team USA we won
but from the perspective of the soccer
ball I got kicked around a lot and I got
no thanks for it yeah you know when I
like that a lot
yeah that that's a great way to explain
how to try and see the empathetic
perspective from behind people's eyes
and like the point isn't to agree the
point is to be able to immerse yourself
in their shoes in it and understand
their worldview and then that's a big
part of our future that empathetic
future every street corner almost now in
developed world has ubiquity and food
where you can get it however you want it
from whatever ethnicity but why don't we
have that for social emotional desires
why can't I go and order empathy from a
very specific style person so this these
are some of the most rooted things in
our evolution and they're not readily
available for us they're very hard for
us to access sometimes and I think the
shows like this as well as long format
interviews shows as well as the movement
towards storytelling and real life
personal storytelling and the moth the
body storytelling fresh air with Terry
Gross etc etc I mean all of that is the
seeking empathy
so you're watching this in order to step
into to other human beings world
perspective so in participating in the
modern movement of storytelling of
narrative of long-form at interviews at
the very moment when it's a Twitterverse
right yeah you know at the very moment
when it's hundred and forty characters
at the very moment when it's seemingly
nothing but knee-jerk reactive
journalism at the same time there's a
huge interest out there you viewers of
stepping towards empathy and
understanding other people's experience
and this is what you guys are doing and
creating this show thank you Midori so
yeah thank you yeah and yeah it's
paramount to push that story forward and
see how it impacts our world when other
people get so excited about taking on
other people's perspectives and what
that means for empathy in our future you
do this in your own way as well your own
beautiful way yeah you actually have
this this very beautiful
give this very beautiful quote in your
book I do BDSM in search of a moment's
clarity and pureness of existence
yeah opening line of my book wild side
sex we're gonna get there I love that
see we carried that same essence of
wanting to get to this deepest aspects
of our psyches and let's let's learn
more about you you're born in Tokyo
actually born in Kyoto but raised in
Tokyo born in Kyoto raised yeah okay I I
was moved to Tokyo so young that I don't
even remember Kyoto really and so then
what was that even like like who were
you as a kid what was the culture like
how did you get interested in things
that you care about okay so my my father
country right and I am multicultural
there's this uncomfortable conversation
that happens in Japan all the time it
also happens here when I introduced
myself and no you know I'm it usually
goes something like this
you know oh that's a Japanese name yes
you're not Japanese I'm Japanese and
they're like oh but you're not fully
Japanese and then the question is in
21st century what does it mean to be
Japanese right I mean what does American
look like because I know what people are
saying is that oh you're and then I
would clarify with the question of do
you mean my parent or ethnic heritage do
you mean my citizenship do you mean my
cultural affiliation do you mean the
foundation of my cultural upbringing or
my my personal and my identification as
to where my culture is from you know
language citizenship nationality
ethnicity the construct of race what do
you mean because you know somebody's not
gonna walk up to you and say oh well you
don't look American you look well
European
well the assumption is what American is
now supposedly white but then what is
American and yeah I am Japanese and I am
also an international international is
what I would call a whole new generation
of those of us who straddle multiple
cultures and we are of the world and yes
there are cultures that we identify with
that we are from we are of but multiples
at the same time so I'm an international
and I am Japanese and I am also American
and the multiplicity and the
intersectionality can exist in one being
I mean that's intersectionality
so growing up in Japan as a
multicultural multi-ethnic going to
public school in Japan was not easy let
me tell you why
yeah well it's when I was growing up it
was very mono racial and in urban areas
that's changing a bit but it's still you
know it's an island nation protected by
the Godwin's
so the ideal and the myth is it's mono
racial but there are actually more than
the one visibly identifiably Japanese
race right so Japanese race and put that
in big bunny ear marks so growing up it
was interesting with my heritage being
Japanese and German American so from my
German American side my grandmother
instilled in me that you are Japanese
you are of Japan but you do not mean to
need to be under the thumb of Japanese
oppression because it is a difficult
culture it is a beautiful culture it is
it has fantastic traditions great food
fantastic food tasty tasty food but it's
also like any other country and culture
and civilizations it's complicated with
its uglier sides so my my grandmother my
feminist German suffered just
grandmother made sure that I saw myself
as citizen of the world and to put my
put my roots down and enjoy the flowers
and the fruits of Japan but then to to
be able to run in the fields of the
ideal of American Liberty but she came
from the early 20th century and fought
for the right for women to vote and she
was looking at a time again
of stubborn dreamers and she came out of
a time when it was she was devastated by
the the Great War World War one had
wreaked havoc upon people in country and
she had survived the depression and
survived World War two and here's a
woman who said don't be a conformist
don't be under the thumb of things
Japanese appreciate Japan would be a
woman of the world Wow
which
made for friction in worldview growing
up in Japan yeah
so I am very much the child of eddore
old name of Tokyo so I consider myself
an otaku child a widow it's like saying
a New Yorker right I'm an OCO I am a
child of the Showa Imperial era the two
Emperor's back now I absolutely am - the
bones have so many things that are
Japanese value at the same time I also
have German American inteligencia
pioneer daughter daughter of American
Revolution in my blood as well one of my
ancestors was on the Mayflower mmm yeah
so that makes work kind of a convoluted
world deal for a little person it's a
beautiful world view I think it just
sets a young person up for so much yes
great in mark thank you in my adulthood
yes the childhood was hard because
Japanese well Japan is a deeply racist
country
just nationalism is yes it's not so much
racism it's just proud national heritage
National ISM but it's also racism I'm
gonna totally own it I mean my culture
of origin is deeply racist so much so
that I was denied citizenship because
I'm mixed
so I might have some feelings around the
current immigration issues so grew up in
Japan went to public school as one of
the few out internationals I mean a
bunch of other kids went to with similar
heritage I think ended up going to
international schools and there are
benefits to that and you also miss up
group miss growing up as Japanese but
then that's that's a whole international
school thing right so I grew up in that
my mother is a scholar in Japanese
literature so I ended up hanging out in
a lot of antiquarian bookstores and old
neighborhoods yeah and going to temples
and going to shrines and let me tell you
the mythology in Japan is fantastic the
ghost stories in Japan yeah
so I grew up with all of that then
around the age of 14 as the teenage
angst hit and the pressure for school
exams and then realizing that what's my
future as a mixed-blood Japanese girl
who comes from a divorced family yeah so
these are all strikes against and female
and on top of that a fire horse fire
horse is my birth year and it's also my
company name that's why my company name
fire horse productions it happens every
sixty years and girls born on this year
are supposedly cursed we can't be tamed
and like horses with fire coming out of
our mains we run roughshod over the men
in our lives and we're not marriage'
born we speak our minds oh no oh yes
right yeah not a blessing in many ways
it is in hindsight but under old
Japanese structure of patriarchy and
reliance accident where women could
access power and privilege through
marriage an arranged marriage at that
too wasn't an option and I'm looking at
my future and going do I really want to
stay here or do I want to go to that
land far away that my grandmother has
told me of
so my teenage hunks you know in the u.s.
you go for sex drugs and rock and roll
when the teenage angst hits in Japan and
the teenage angst hit you hit suicide I
had a third out go to the US
so I ended up up in Washington State
with my grandmother you went with
Grandma
I went yeah and she was like okay time
to go Wow yeah
she had a massive influence on the
worldview in your life oh yeah and and
so did my mother and her ability and my
mother still alive she's in Tokyo she
has this genius genius human being right
and like so many geniuses have slightly
difficult time dealing with actual
ordinary humans but she has this ability
to connect the dots right connect dots
and seemingly disparate historical facts
I think I got that for my mother not in
the historical facts but disparate
seemingly disparate aspect of human
desire and creativity
so now growing up in Japan the sexual
attitudes are very different there it's
modesty and context appropriateness and
it's about shame not guilt in
judeo-christian West especially in the
United States now that that there's a
strong evangelical influence and strong
Christian influence right the electric
third well and that which charges the
sexual element or culture here is guilt
guilt is that there is an omniscient
other with some sort of constancy in in
a rule and rules they can that's
constant through context right and that
there's a big guy up there who knows if
you've been naughty or nice wait that
Santa he sees you and you're sleeping
give it to be good for goodness sake
yeah and he sees you when you're jacking
off and he sees you when you're lying
and he's easier when you're running
around and in frilly panties or a
business suit so the Western
civilization assumes a constancy in
constancy and universality of right and
wrong in Japan the electric third-rail
of desire and that which is the force of
of social guilt and shame are powerful
and as a socialist tribal structure
right in Japan its shame shame is a
horizontal structure as opposed to
vertical horizontal cultural context
what is my position in society and my
responsibilities right now will I make
you uncomfortable will I bring
disharmony to the context now so for
example if you and I were working in the
same company the social contract is we
would not talk about our personal lives
at all which makes a really dull Monday
morning conversation nobody talks about
what happens on the weekend but on the
other hand if you and I also happen to
belong to the same sex club
I you know you might see me running
around in a giant octopus outfit and
I'll see you running around in frilly
panties and we'd be like hey dude how's
it goin and we won't talk about work at
all and it would be entirely appropriate
within the closed doors and the social
context we shatter all the taboos so in
Japan you don't have that and so I
didn't grow up with the oh my god this
is bad it is sin I did grow up with its
what I'm doing making you uncomfortable
there's a socially appropriate so coming
over to the u.s. I didn't have the the
guilt around the desire but I was very
concerned about is this the right place
though the spirit of your grandmother
assisted with your spirit of all being
here yeah yeah and then what what
happened when you got here and you're
experiencing you ask oh man I was that
weird nerdy foreign student weird nerdy
foreign student I was fascinated with
old clothing before it was fashionable
and called vintage clothing so I was
that weird foreign student in odd old
clothing I think in like The Breakfast
Club I might have been like the goth
girl no I wasn't even that coordinated
no no I was like that okay drama guild
academic decathlon the German club and
doing my calculus homework on a Saturday
night that was me that was me oh my god
total dork
yeah stressing over tests
that's a big leap to now from that yeah
I I loosened up yeah I was like uptight
I think no I was I was a good asian kid
I wanted to do well in school they liked
school and I didn't understand this need
to not do well in school and of course
I'm doing this all in the language I
didn't have before
at rudimentary English like a family
pidgin and so now suddenly dumped into
like public high school in the US and I
felt like a Martian observing the mating
habits of another species yeah so I feel
daily sometimes yeah yeah I don't
understand this whole like like American
kids were like at that point that we're
like fascinated with like hickeys and
I'm why are you bringing up blood to the
surface I don't understand you're
latched on like a lamprey on the shark
what I don't understand
there were like certain things about
American teenage sexuality and mating
habits that I just did not understand
so I would be that kid in and then I and
I fell in with all the the Nerds and the
weirdos right I'm the theater kid and
well yeah the a/v Club guys it was like
one one guy who was like you know one
guy who was like cross subculture and
cross tribal he was like smart guy as
well as bandleader and ran with the
football kids but also like hung out
with the weird like av kid and so he was
like the only one that I think made it
through the tribes but you know I would
be the one sitting in the cafeteria on
Monday morning listening to the sexual
exploits of the one one girl who was had
a mohawk and had like permissive parents
and told us stories of her adventure and
I'd be like ah such fascinating American
mating habits and that was just really
interesting I spent a lot of time
listening and curious and all the while
I had a rich fantasy life of my own that
was entirely my own
and so I was this weirdly dressed kid
who was only focused on seemingly only
focused on on schoolwork but all the
while I'm watching like some little
x-files alien of the other kids but at
home I would rummage through my mother's
beautiful vintage clothing from like
these Jackie O dresses from the sixties
and I would like dress myself up and put
on like drag queen level makeup like
stare at myself in the mirror and
transformation and somehow weirdly
aroused by and I don't mean weirdly in
the judgmental way but somehow aroused
by this creature I saw in the mirror so
I would like to change my outfits hmm
over and over and I had a rich fantasy
life and me and my right hand got along
great yeah
no consent issues there hi yes I would
like you to test me I don't want to
touch you yes yeah that's great
yeah I was very sexual with myself
because I came from Tokyo through a
little cow town in Washington I also
urban elitism saved me from teenage
pressure urban elitism and just being
this strange alien kid right
and because I came from this big city
right I was already hanging out in jazz
bars with my mother are going to
political meetings tagging along
you know and in the city of millions and
then going to a cow town so I kind of
had this idea that well anything that
the teenagers are into here must be
stupid so I had that kind of urban
elitism which in the long run saved me
from a lot of things that
I'm glad that I didn't get peer
pressured into
you know yeah it's in some in some ways
the humans moving into metropolis that
are now melting pots of different
cultures and certain people that are
very like hyper creative that are trying
to spread memes or ideas around the
world it's a cool place to be although
it's a time is very disconnecting from
nature and then what about how you ended
up you know you're talking a bit about
that you're look you're putting on
different outfits you're getting along
really well through right hand you know
all these types of things you have a big
fantasy world but then how does that get
you into becoming an author and an
artist
sex educator yes No so you know I gotta
say though recently back to the high
school part my that rush I'm own thing
the different perspective how I saw
myself in high school apparently was not
how some of my friends saw me yeah and
yeah and I was so surprised recently
when I heard from somebody I knew in
high school who told me that I was one
of the most confident and grounded
people she knew in high school and I was
like what what
that's so interesting and apparently I
was an influence on her I had no idea I
was just quietly listening and watching
and doing my own thing
as an advantage to not fitting in and
just accepting that but she thought I
was confident and rounded like yeah
decades later I find out so that
Rashomon effect right I had no idea
that's how I thought um I ended up along
the way
on a whim enlisted in the US Army haha
that happened
it seemed like it was an impulse I like
the outfit I think but also I had a
certain bit of draw - oh yeah I didn't
mention that huh I think I was drawn to
this masculine environment because I
grew up in an intellectual feminist
female household and there's a part of
me that sought out something of the
warrior something of the mask and not to
say male but masculine and in hindsight
I recognize that I was creating my own
rite of passage
yes you know it makes sense when we look
back connect-the-dots yeah yeah yeah you
went to another like hyper extreme in
the edge and you learned something
completely new that would be super
essential - what do you know now yeah
and I didn't realize that I was
physically strong I didn't realize that
I had the capacity to deal with
physically intense situations now I
served during peacetime so my experience
was not that of actually being being in
a campaign or being in combat I served
during peacetime but I still had to take
some military history classes and
learning command voice and jump out of
airplanes and things like that and and
learn the organizational structures so I
created my own right of passage and I'm
glad for that I ended up a cow what was
your wife oh I was 35 Delta in which
that Soviet technical intelligence
analyst and Soviet Soviet oh my god and
then they fell apart so there went my
job and it sounds so glamorous like yeah
so I ended up getting my Commission in
military intelligence it's not what it's
no it's it's an oxymoron yes absolutely
announcer
in turn it is I was chair born all the
way it's kind of like it's it's
essentially silly
identification game can I identify this
silhouette of a tank and based upon neck
and based upon the knowledge of the
Soviet tactical doctrine can identify
what kind of unit is there it's puzzle
pieces I wanted to fly helicopters but I
ended up Intel
so then I end up at Cal and kind of
served five year sentence they're trying
to figure out what I wanted to do and
had no idea no idea I have no training
and public speaking Oh actually I lie
you know who trained me in public
speaking no to two sources one was Uncle
Sam so when I was in the service I had
to learn how to give briefings I have to
learn how to give briefings of analysis
summary to the higher-ups I had to give
mission briefings and that's public
speaking skills so I learned that yeah
and I floated through Cal and I probably
should have studied so she but I just
kind of had to declare a major and ended
up declaring psych
but back then Cal was I don't know what
it how it is now but it was very
neurobiological and abnormal psych based
and I'm more interested in how the
strategies of ordinary people in
navigating through this very complicated
real life
so yeah college was I just stumbled
through it
probably would have been better suited
in some other schools but I survived
the grinder that is Cal yeah go bears
I ended up in San Francisco shortly
thereafter and now I'm landing in San
Francisco at the end of the end of the
worst of the plague so I am this young
woman who's coming into my adulthood and
my sexuality and ending up in San
Francisco as a dark cloud of of AIDS
hangs over the city as a generation of
people wiped out in this unforgiving
wave of death and hatred because it's
not just the depth it's when politicians
are saying let's round these people up
and quarantine them maybe even gas them
when the president cannot address this
pandemic when families are abandoning
their grown children and bodies go
unclaimed when physicians and health
practitioners won't touch people when
the food of the patients would not be
taken away because the health care
workers did not want to touch them when
if you said hello to somebody six months
later they're dead
and people were at people were at discos
and nightclubs and sex parties may be
having their last dance their last [ __ ]
I'm getting for club just thinking about
it this is very profoundly moving yes
the description of the AIDS epidemic
yeah when I find most peculiar about
that epidemic if it happened not too
long after the the white riots after did
Danny white was acquitted and then the
the riots and they burned the police
cars and tore the city up but then the
next thing we're dealing with aids and
like you say the politicians are blaming
the activity well if you you know don't
mess around with the same sex you won't
have to worry about that those are
around those are interesting times and
rest my uncle rich and Nick the most
positive influences of my family on my
mother's side we lost them young to that
they inspired me with creativity and
imagination and just free-spirited so
thank you for sharing your story
I'm gonna need a tissue we have
somewhere oh good good good
yay yeah make me offer clamped here we
lost an entire generation of creative
force oh yeah
so I end up in San Francisco right as
that's going on right and what year is
this mmm that is 91 jeez yeah
surrounded just around the time that I
was born mm-hmm
so 91 and that's also right around the
time of the the growth of the valley in
terms of the technology software push
and the computing era mm-hmm yeah and
the the glory that is the technological
boom of San Francisco is built literally
on the shoulders and the backs of dead
people and if it were not for the people
that gave a [ __ ] you know the stubborn
dreamers I like act up the whole process
of now what's the big pharma industry
and their ability to push through
experimental drugs into the market that
wouldn't be happening if not for the
act-up folks and the break it and make
it that whole ethos of let's look at
things and change it and let's change it
from the ground up and the whole sex
positive culture as well has owes a lot
to the reality of being disowned
abandoned and dying
you got a change of system because the
system doesn't care if you die and what
you know part of the the freedom that we
seem to enjoy in San Francisco is on
literal backs of dead people
these stories are so important we had a
similar conversation with those that
sacrificed so much to make the push for
cannabis as well and for those that push
for civil rights for those that push for
women's rights for those that
pushed four degrees of economic freedom
around the planet people that are even
today sacrificing themselves to make it
so that they can decrease the amount of
corruption and and greed in malevolence
around the world and increase the amount
of freedom dignity prosperity peace
these stories need to be shared and it's
like though one of the things that
really makes my heart sink is when
someone comes to San Francisco and then
works in a tech company for a year and
they've never visited the Pacific Ocean
there's no I've never dived into the
I've never dived into the history of
what has made this place so great and or
even how the place itself was had many
indigenous people that have been
and the amount of reciprocity and love
that hasn't been apologizing that hasn't
been made in yeah so there's a lot there
and I'm happy that you've brought us to
do that and I landed in San Cisco from
Berkeley and right around then and in
that moment as I'm I'm coming into San
Francisco
I don't see the big picture because in
the moment you don't see the big picture
right what I but I realized that people
dying was a norm it shouldn't be a norm
but it was my norm
ah
getting getting all teary-eyed but you
know the effect of this was I ended up
and it was at the time when I was coming
into my own sexuality right in my own my
own excitement is whoo sex with other
people not just my right hand in the
showerhead
yay gotta love the shower heads about
the shower shower head yeah since since
I was a little one I was a water
masturbator
but yeah so woo sex with other people
and I have my own apartment instead of a
roommate situation yay right so I'm I'm
working in like some going nowhere
administrative job downtown and had an
idea I had no idea what I wanted to do
for a career and I wasn't one of these
like smart ambitious college student was
like I shall be an engineer I will get
an MBA I will be a neurosurgeon and I
was like I will get groceries hey you
know yeah so you know I have my own
apartment yay I got a paycheck yay I
have a cat yay whoo I see a flyer for a
dance club I figure out it's a gay dance
club I go dancing yay
handsome men who will flirt and dance
with me but it seems it's a gay club so
it was sexy and fun and safe
and the meantime I'm not fully aware but
somewhere in my bones I'm aware that I'm
surrounded by people who are dancing
with deep joy because they could be dead
in a few months do I understand that
passion no I don't not until later so
yeah
other clubs were fun how can we live
with that sense of
being in the moment it only yeah there
only comes I think it was believed it
was Tim Timothy O'Leary fed on the path
out that he said that he could see
eternity and even the blade of grass
something like that mm-hm
can we see that really Timothy Leary and
I think salesman theory I think it was
him who said the Merry Pranksters and
yeah can we can we really live that much
in the moment we can death on the front
door yeah that's yeah that's really
really present you know knock knock
knock hello death calling not my time to
go yet no okay fine I'll come back later
dance while you can cuz I'm coming to
get ya
so and then I end up finding flyers and
little you know this is like before the
Internet
right so or Internet's there but not the
web with easier access and I think I was
alright for those of you who've been
around I was hanging out on the well a
bit the well the well
sorry I don't know the Wow oh the well
was was an early internet bulletin board
yeah Bay area-based bulletin board
service yeah it's like you know internet
archaeology there but I started finding
interesting little flyers about like
erotic poetry readings and then there
was some fetish club and then I would
get I'm terribly shy right terribly sure
I haven't really found my own voice if
you will but there were these places I
could get dressed up into neat
expressions of myself and go so I would
create outfits with you know not nothing
sophisticated with like glue guns and
creative combinations of wardrobe and
makeup and I would come up with outfits
and go to these events alone and night
clubs and events I wasn't much of a
drinker and wasn't much into drugs at
all but I liked the opportunity of
self-expression yeah and so that
dressing up little girl was allowed
dressing up and then I realized that if
I dressed up in some way that was an
interesting outfit and of some theme
some outfit then it seemed to open doors
for conversations with people
and kind of met people and met some nice
people and got cruised by some nice
people and I ended up falling into crews
by stubborn dreamers and idealist who
believed that sexuality is part of the
human condition and human right and
having safe accurate information about
to make one's own sexual decisions being
so important and that that was my
friends that got me into San Francisco
sex information this is before it was
called the sex positive movement I need
to read this this quote from you there
is no virginity to be lost only
adulthood to be gained yep yep and to
have the right resources that are
accurate for our actual explorations and
to be able to make individual decisions
based upon safe accurate and
judgment-free information
so I fell into a group of determined
idealist who saw that the pursuit of
pleasure was not not a path for self
annihilation but self-expression mm-hmm
this is the classic right hand or left
hand path yeah do we pursue the
pleasures for identifying
self-expression and connection with the
source or do we stay in ascetic and
abstain from overindulging and self off
of those pleasures took form to
overindulge who obliteration and to
disconnect for obliterates any other so
yeah
it's a classic conversation that's been
had for a really long time by by
philosophers and so I ended up falling
in with a group of people who were nice
and fun and sexy and taught me some
basic things about good sexual
communication and different ways of
looking at relationship and and sex and
intimacy and this was like the bleeding
edge of culture and I got lucky I didn't
even know that the time that I was
falling in with this really intensely
bleeding edge subculture that was
exploring yeah not exploring orgasm not
as an act of selfishness but
self-expression and pursuit of what we
now call authenticity and community
forming and re-examining value based
upon social justice
yeah at the cutting edge of the
subculture forming yeah yeah and then
the people that I met were they were
just okay let's see I met people that
were named Joanie and Annie and Pat who
became Patrick and Carol and Robert and
these were all people that were making
culture
Annie sprinkle Carol Queen Robert
Lawrence Patrick Olivia Joanie Blank etc
etc and they and [ __ ] you miss afar and
these are lists of leaders in the field
that were at the edge of the subculture
developing this was in the early 90s
yeah and they were just fun sexy people
who were nice to me because I'm just
this young person
and I think I was relatively stable and
seemingly
considerate interesting enough I kind of
tagged along hanging out with them and
started helping out and I would you know
I wasn't so world aware and enlightened
as to say that I'm going to protest and
change the world now it was like
somebody asking okay we're gonna go to a
safer sex live demo at a sex club come
help okay
because the public health officials as
much as they wanted to their hands were
tied they could just stand behind a
table and hand out condoms and say use a
condom or you die I mean that's all that
they could do because the the municipal
or government funding whereas a band of
merry perverts could bridge the gap of
information and to teach from not just
smart sex but smarter hotter sex it
wasn't just safe sex right safe sex
assume for well if you have sex you'll
die it's like a bad horror movie as
opposed to hey we're humans we have we
get to have sex but why don't we have it
smarter because there's some things that
could happen and some of the things
could happen on one side is the death
but sometimes it's a broken heart and
that sucks too
and to know how to have the feeling of
knowing what to do in those moments are
so important and to be able to talk to
other people about those moments yeah
yeah and so I ended up saying yes to a
lot of things and when I say yes to a
lot of things I don't mean yes as in
disregarding my own boundary but I mean
yes to people saying okay there's this
thing we need help there's we need
somebody to staff the table we need
somebody to step up and start staffing
the phone for providing sex information
we need somebody to come out and help
out with a live safer sex demo okay
we need some more at the nightclub I
would hang out with the hang out at men
would show up every week in a different
outfit I was a regular infant half-cycle
outfits and somebody that was a regular
performer would say oh hey I want to
come up and perform be part of a fashion
show I'm starting a latex company okay I
want to come up on stage and dance with
me and Daisy the 12 foot long boa
constrictor okay hey what are you doing
there oh this is called flogging I will
show you okay
you were in school I was in school I was
like Alice in Wonderland
yeah and you know I was sitting around
with the Mad Hatter and I was sitting
around with the Queen of Hearts and and
playing croquet with pink flamingos and
I just didn't know it was not normal
yeah they became the norm being at the
edge became the norm yeah yeah that's
pretty cool yeah and all the while I'm
still the nerdy girl who's curious about
human strategy but now instead of
feeling like an alien among different
species I parently these people are Wow
amazing and so I found myself in awe and
Wonder in adventure and in the meantime
I am not worried at all about a career I
like you know completely a fool when it
came to being a responsible capitalist
system cog in the wheel I made a living
well enough to pay for the rent of a
studio that in San Francisco I could
still afford them oh my god I kind of I
was suppose I should have worried more
about money
I wasn't money driven
it was still awfully curious about
people I seem to have completely
abandoned any sort of grade I must
achieve this great I must achieve this
success because I was already born
outside of the way that I was born I was
born outside of expectations of success
and whatever that meant
so I'm down the rabbit hole you know
having a good time and going to
exploring at very sex parties thrown by
nice people and sitting in cafes with
leather men and leather dyke talking
about the experience of what is it like
and we would be discussing like the
emotional states of experiences and some
of the people that I knew were you know
forward revolutionaries and out marching
in the streets I was a little shy about
that stuff but along the way somebody
noticed that I was accumulating a lot of
skill and had some opinions so a local
sex newspaper editor approached me said
hey you have some interesting ideas
would you be interested in writing and
I'm like oh no I can't write I know no
and you know I had that like you know
the Japanese student I can't write I
can't write and he Lane Winkle black who
was a publisher of Spectator magazine
along with his partner cat some love and
I owe him a lot because he took me out
to dinner and started to pick my brain
about my worldview and my philosophies
and my adventuring into alternative
sexuality and adventuring into what
would soon become called BDSM was just
called sfm
or leather and I'm hanging out with the
black leather wings and I'm hanging out
with leather man hanging out with San
Francisco sex information I'm hanging
out with fetish clubs and Lane says you
know you have some interesting
perspectives yeah could you write a
monthly column yes English second
language eek yeah and he's like I'm an
editor that's my job just put your
thoughts down and I'll fix it okay and
dinners on me okay and I'll pay you for
it really really oh my god okay I'm
gonna need a lot of help it's like okay
that's fine I'll help you yeah
and so it's so cool to report that's
real journalism to find these
subcultures evolving find the people at
the edge and and ask them hey will you
help write something monthly about the
subculture and you know we can help yeah
I'm you with that and pay you for that I
that's that's beautiful and it's
completely different than the crap
that's circulating in the mainstream
media he had to push me pull me nurture
me challenge me and 2,000 words every
month many of the essays ended up in
wild tonight sex so I started writing
and I got no writing training in college
I mean I wrote term papers but that
doesn't count right because I wasn't
writing about me and my experiences I
had no ambitions to be a writer I didn't
even know I could somebody so could you
write about your experience a little bit
don't worry we'll edit it okay sure
and so meantime Alice in Wonderland here
starts writing about her adventures and
and then I start to take apart because I
was fascinated with the why and again
back to the curiosity about the
strategies of ordinary people right and
I would start to ask people because I
had this writing and deadlines it gave
me an excuse to ask people and there
were these cafe conversations that
happened and when we were sitting around
in cafes and bars at least my cohorts we
weren't talking about Oh stock options
and beta testing and all that stuff now
now we weren't talking about tech
developments we were talking about life
development but not like life coaching
but it's like oh my god I tried this
thing and it really I just really [ __ ]
that up Wow
whatever you don't with that and what's
this about and and I am I'm having all
these feelings and that helped me
explain it these are the conversations
we were having
it was
revolutionary and we didn't know it you
know so I started writing columns and
then the columns caught the attention of
somebody who is doing little workshops
in the corner kinky bookstore and she's
like why don't you teach a class and I
see that you know you've been you know
writing stuff and like I don't know I
can't teach uh here's a format here's a
structure just follow this and just talk
about what you know you just you got I
give you two hours and I'll pay you for
it
talk what you know yeah okay sure
in the meantime I've had some public
speaking training through San Francisco
sex information right so I had some of
that training but I'm like oh okay
I think the first class that I taught
was I think 96 maybe yeah
95 or 96 somewhere in there in 94 95 I
ended up going to Burning Man 94 and 95
that's a very different event so I
turned out that I could teach I didn't
know that lo and behold apparently
watching my mother teaching taught me a
few things my mother is actually not a
good teacher she's a genius but she
assumes everybody has the same genius
level attention I'm a little funnier
yeah so yeah you know so and I didn't
know what was funny but I would point
out real things and apparently it was
funny
you're still writing monthly and you're
teaching and and and this is like on the
side and I'm doing a going nowhere job
that pays the rent and I'm adventuring
in the city and trying out sex parties
and and exploring with with lovers and
and beautiful beautiful relationships
scandalous ones passionate ones
it's far away look let's talk about your
art yeah just just to like be able to
comfortably talk about our sexual
experience is to make that not taboo
anymore that's so important
now you said let's talk about my art but
yeah so he has the roots in the
nightclub Thanks
remember I said something about being
invited up onto the stage and doing
weird ass [ __ ] with people who were
doing well it would be called
performance art and so I started doing
things the dance at the boa constrictors
you the boa constrictor you bet and then
I started creating imageries that we're
playing in the grotesque and then I end
up meeting people like Scott from the
mystic Midway local character and start
creating and and dabbling into
performance art stuff there we go there
are some characters of mine oh hey yeah
yeah so we we went through a couple
things while we were talking we were we
we showed you a little bit on on
firehorse productions holds all these
different things one of them is rope
dojo which teaches about rope we
probably we went we went through these
images all just educate people on what
we went through there were teachers
about real control and you guys can you
guys can go and look at those events
again I'll give a short version I teach
a lot of stuff a lot of things around
rope bondage women's dominance intensive
using your voice for sex and the hotness
I teach a bunch of hot things it'll it's
fun show up as a date night fort FM
though that's for women to tap into
their authentic power it's awesome but
let's talk about my art yeah yeah let's
go back to now let's go back to Forte
family oh okay I just want to mom I just
want to really move these shows so that
I just want these shows to be under an
hour Alan oh and I don't want you to
take it
Vantage of let's move these shows Alan
so forth mm of my art which should we
talk about 40cm
all right so forth mm I'm super excited
about Fort FM I started that in what
2000 I want to say to 2002 or 2004 it is
a three-day intensive myself and nine
women in either SAMHSA's core in New
York and it is it is a women's dominance
weekend intensive however it is not
about what the wacky pokey binding
things it is about how to tap into your
authentic power and to unleash it from
the bedroom to the boardroom I'm using
BDSM and King as a sandbox a portal of
exploration of power and I think most
people are kinky in some way or another
you know from maybe somebody who just
likes a little booty sumac and a little
nipple tweak once in a while all the way
to something incredibly intense or
psychologically deep and exploratory
most people are kinky it's a human
condition
it's a beautiful spectrum the occasional
booty slap or nipple twist all the way
to being completely wrote and the books
have a tremendous you know we showed
those as well the books actually have a
tremendous amount of of explanation to
how to do this safely and how to do it
in a way that is smart and compassionate
and compassionate you have that empathy
for getting behind the world mucus it's
it's experiencing a state of
consciousness that's non-ordinary a
state of consciousness that that is a
it's a beautiful feeling of emotions
experience and so yeah we we showed some
of the some of the other books we were
just talking about for them that's also
on the links in the bow to check out and
the amount of of also art that youth
days made is just and I love the art
because it's I do want to go measure
because it's not what people think we
have we have a graduate Society of
amazing women they are c-level CEOs CFOs
heads of heads of departments
entrepreneurs these are women who are
finding ways by which to figure out
collaborative power engagement in their
bedroom and they're taking it from the
bedroom and being true to what would
please them now
and to look at that as a model of
creating to collaboratively create
mutual satisfaction now if we can do
that in the bedroom
yet on the planet right yeah and there's
this quiet secret society of fort FM
graduates yeah beautiful and they're
making amazing things happen I'm so
excited about them but yeah yeah the way
that you unleash your authentic power
from the border into a bedroom yeah
women's dominance intensive and what the
skills learned can help on the whole
planetary level completely yeah yeah its
massive yep yeah I love it
this is about my art more to unpack on
future shows absolutely that's yeah good
critical principle yeah so it's
everything from performance art
installations painting evil vocal
multi-phase project but how we create
hold interpret and alter memory is my
family Samar and oh prince was lovely to
work with that was at a recent
performance gorgeous yeah
and then this one is yeah mama
yeah Mamba it was in the dusty edge of
the primordial forest on the fringe of
civilization subconscious no I loved
embodying a Mamba yeah
and then hold aku Oh toka to uncoil yeah
the ancient one beneath all the cover-up
is an animal heart a puzzle new to be
solved by her alone and that speaks to
all of us cuz right inside is an animal
heart that is our own process of
self-discovery yeah kimono - yeah kimono
- what we wear yeah well we wear
expectations and commodification of
Japanese American woman today plastics
you showed a massive exhibit of blowup
dolls that are clicked together like
IKEA furniture to showcase kind of like
hungry culture fed on individuals and
security fears and inadequacies oh yeah
and that's the loveseat the loveseat is
yeah part of the body of work called
plastics and it's meant to be sat on
exactly yeah and it's meant to be sat on
and it creates it inspires conversations
interesting conversations between people
because there's this vulgar object yeah
right and creating this funny thing but
underneath the humor and the goofiness
is this deep cultural horror because all
of these things all the the blow-up
dolls
I mean who talks about owning a blow-up
doll they don't it's and yet it's
thousands thousands upon thousands of
these are made using precious resource
exploiting labor in in other countries
creating toxic byproducts and then
carbon footprint to bring us that and
then their body parts that are
replaceable like commodified female
bodies and sexual imagery are women
and all right fine I'll make a couch out
of it and force people to talk about it
by sitting on it and and initially it's
hahaha and then they realize the
grotesqueness of it yeah it inspires the
conversations that need to I love
playing with the grotesque I love
playing with the unexpected I love
playing with with a bit of humor oh this
this because they're the people that
come to the dining room actually get to
break the plates first and then you
assemble it into like a carpet
underneath of the dining room table
I throw what I call the shadow party and
invite people to break this chatter
party yeah and there's such an
exhilaration and release of emotion when
people are breaking the dishes and then
I collected into the carpet and I wanted
to create an imagery that cut across
class and demographics to address
the unseen worlds and our families of
origin
dawn seen wounds in the families of
origin yeah we're typically not
highlighting to our unseen wounds we are
very stoic about those and yeah
everything's fine everything's fine yep
and the the plates on the tabletops
actually were broken and then I glued
them back together for this semblance of
normalcy and nothing is cracked no no
it's not everything's fine they're
Windows when this exhibition has gone up
in a few places it brings forth torrent
of emotions with the attendees there's a
mirror on the other side and as you're
approaching the insulation and you look
at it through this window and your
reflection is in the mirror it places
you in the exhibit in the dining that's
great yeah
and you become an accomplice yeah
in the silence I love it I love your art
installations I'm excited we'll be able
to unpack more on our installations on
the writing because all of the books are
are unique and beautiful in their own
way that we'll get to to talk about as
well in future conversations and and
also getting a little bit deeper into
the neuroscience of certain things in
the future I'd like to talk to you about
that yeah yeah yeah we'll we'll get to
we'll get to jump into some of those
conversations more and on the safety of
all of these things on the on how it
drives us more to things like the the
the moments clarity and pureness of
existence so I'm looking forward to
those conversations in our future Midori
this has been really fun getting to know
you better and showcasing all this make
me cry you thank you really appreciate
it thank you thank you thanks Ron for
producing and directing we really
appreciate it Ron shadows desires and
creativity everyone give us your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode we'd love to hear from you also
do check out the links in the bio as
well again Ron Cheng calm and Fort femme
calm and FHP - Inc calm and the Twitter
Facebook Instagram YouTube patreon
profile if you don't support my patreon
because I'm working on my next bondage
book he is working on the next bondage
book support on patreon to help with
that process to have more conversations
of your friends families co-workers
people online on social media about
shadows desires creativity and all the
things that we talked about today or
sexuality BDSM self-expression let's get
talking about that more and support the
artists entrepreneurs organizations
spiritual leaders like Midori like
simulation her links are below ours are
also below - patreon cryptocurrency
PayPal and design cool merch you can pay
to all the cool stuffs below for you to
check out and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dream since the
oil thing
so much for tuning in we'll see you soon
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]